sine and cosine but now what we're going
to do is rest them on that previous
knowledge of functions to take these
basic ideas and then just extend them a
little bit just a little bit so for
example if we have a look at the TV
together I think they're asking us to do
is it two sine theta is that what it
says y equals two sine theta okay now I
want you to think back before we think
about this is a Trina metric function I
want you to think back just to regular
functions if for example you knew what
the graph of y equals x squared looked
like picture in your mind y equals x
squared what kind of shape is that by
the way what name do we give it its
parabola thank you very much now if I
chuck it to at the front if I multiply
that whole thing by two it doesn't
change the basic nature of the shape
it's still a parabola but what's the
difference between them yeah it's you
could say it's steeper right you could
also say it's narrower they're kind of
two ways to say the same thing so if for
example you compare these two what would
just look like another one another
version of the other one which just
needs to lose some weight right now it's
the same deal here with sine theta and
to side Thea right a point that we would
have gone through before like say 1 1
when we multiply by 2 we're gonna go
through 1 1 anymore do we
we're gonna go through something twice
as high cuz I'm multiplying by 2 right
it won't be 1 1 it'll be hmm then
carefully it's going higher right
x-coordinate is still 1 it's the Y here
we got there eventually all right it's
the y-coordinate the changes to 2 right
now when you take this over to our side
graph right
previously we went up to how high did we
go how high did your same graph go 1
right and how low did it go negative 1
right so when you slap a 2 at the front
you're multiplying the whole thing my
two you're not going to go up to 1
anymore you go to go up to 2 and also
the safety cap is down below it's going
to get a negative so in fact this is
slightly cheap but the shape is
essentially maintained the shape is
essentially maintained but it's
going up to one I'm just gonna call that
two and instead of going down to
negative one I'm gonna call that man
gave two but of course just like with
every other graph you've done all the
intercepts matter I actually haven't
drawn any intercepts on this I used to
go from 1 to negative 1 I'm multiplying
everything by 2 so when I what angle was
this 270 degrees or 3pi on to so when
you put in sine of 3 point 2 into your
calculator you normally will get
negative 1 but I'm putting to sign a 3
point 2 so you'll get to here - okay
my Internet's here what are these
important angles let's do it all in
radians now let's try and stop doing it
in degrees I've taken the picture up so
where do I begin
that's easy 1 0 halfway across I'm in
radians I'm hearing some pies right
halfway across this is the whole circle
right maybe I should ask the better
question at the end this is all the way
around the circle how many radians is
that that's Supai that's the whole
revolution
so therefore halfway there is pi okay we
could also put in your PI on June and
your three-pound - ok
it looks just like your original
spaghetti graph but your vertical scales
are different okay we haven't looked at
all at um 10 yet we haven't looked at
all at 10 I'm not going to make you do
this spaghetti for that because if you
remember how we showed that that's
actually gonna need a lot of spaghetti
and it's very hard to figure out okay
but you do have a calculator there which
can work out what those distances are
you also have desmos you're going to do
sign like so we do cosine then we're
gonna do 10 lastly one thing I should
probably finish is say when you got
there - there right that's at the front
so you multiply the whole thing by - it
gets stretched out like this what if in
fact I think it is actual questions say
I'm just gonna write it here and someone
can tell me if it is what happens if the
two is inside if I've records here that
ah
so you already have an instinct because
of all the time we spent on functions
right CBS 2 is really actually mucking
around with the with the Y it's an
up-down thing right but see this
I hear that - is all the way tucked
inside on the feeder which is the
horizontal axis so this in fact is not
going to go up and down it's gonna be
kind of like an accordion it's gonna
squeeze in right like this
Sookie draw another set of axes
underneath this by the way is this to
see is it is it actually can see okay
that's fine I'm gonna do this one anyway
because I want to when you put in some
angles on this right for example if the
angle you wanted to put it was PI then
when you put this into your calculator
what your accountant evaluate is sine of
two times the egg you just put in two pi
right so that's like being at the end of
your graph going all the way around the
circle so instead of going from up and
down all the way in the one hole nought
to 2 pi sorry it's my second or way not
to 2 pi okay we're only gonna do that
for naught 2 pi we're gonna get this
whole shape in half the space can I say
that again because you've got this 2
here right you're going to get this same
whole shape in half of the horizontal
space
so therefore when we got this shape
before alright there's the whole thing
but it only took us till PI to get there
and I'm pretty sure they want us to draw
all of these from in fact I think they
want us to you know it was right from
naught to 2 pi I've got to keep on going
again right so I'm gonna get the same
shape I should have drawn more space
over here over here okay now think about
this you're gonna keep pop some values
into your calculator to see when you're
putting in a value like say if this is
wrong one if this is 2 PI over here that
must be 3 PI on 2 when you reach for
your calculator can you do this actually
for me now get your physical calculator
out I can prove to you how we get this
right kind of shape if you take sine of
2 times that sine of 2 times that then
you're going for this particular example
think about it carefully 2 times 3 PI on
to what happens there is 26.2 we'll give
you just three PI right hmm take your
pick up your unit circle for a second
pick up your new circle
where's the 3 PI on here
pick up your circle for a second little
really pick it up right let's start over
here when I go up to this spot here I've
gone all the way I've started from 0 up
to here what's this angle in radians
radians PI L - thank you
I've gone to here I'm now at PI I'm
gonna skip a little bit and go all the
way back to here to PI so where's 3 PI
you you're gonna go one more pie every
PI here is a half revolution 360 plus
180 540 degrees but I'm trying to think
as much I can eat pies right so
therefore 3 PI is over here what is the
sine of this corner is sign up or down
or left right side so it's up and down
how far up and down alone
am I at this particular point yeah I'm
not up or down I'm right in the middle
of the circle which is why I get 0 see
that that makes sense
so sine of two times that gives you this
sine of 3 PI which is over here ok and
you can always use the unit circle to
work things out so the 2 pi the way I
like to think about it is it's kind of
like two copies of the regular sine two
copies within that space I should
probably like you as well
marking the rest of these intercepts
they're all important that's still gonna
be one and that's still gonna be
negative one okay